and specifically on the vote what would
having the right to vote have to do with
family cohesion for example well because
again before you weren't trying to
divide a family it was one family unit
you had one vote for the family I mean I
don't think it's good for a family to
have two votes I feel like you know the
statute of putting down are perhaps
correct in some years they just kind of
don't really add up I mean just just to
take you back to the to the women's
writings that you've allegedly read I
mean absolutely what do you mean a
legend but at the time that you're
talking about you know women weren't
really allowed to write they weren't
allowed to go to school
that's incorrect the first female
property the first female property owner
was in the 1600s the idea that women
couldn't work
no the first no no the first female the
first female millionaire was in the late
1800s so no it wasn't it was self-made
yes it was made yes it was